we got a little bit of a problem now we
got a little bit of an issue because the
American Media in their infinite wisdom
has been saying for the last two months
that Russia has been losing the war
that Russia's a big [ __ ] and then
everybody who lives in Russia can barely
like put two hands together to fight and
the Russian military is useless and
they've been losing the war now
apparently that offended Putin the
leader of Russia uh and the Ukrainian is
getting like really emboldened which
listen we're all we all want less war
right I want less war
I don't want a nuclear war I don't want
to totally
say that a nuclear war would be horrible
because I think there are a lot of
people in our country who through a lot
of nice editorials including one I
talked about months on the show we're
like hey it's a little bit of a nuclear
war it might not be the biggest deal so
I don't want to listen would a nuclear
war of benefits sure everything has
benefits so I wouldn't want to
completely write off a nuclear war as
all negative I'm sure there's positives
and the people and they'll exploit the
defense contractors will explain to you
the positives of a little nuclear reset
that's why they're just saying tactical
nukes they're using these words tactical
it's not a big it's tactical it's a
tactical new it's a little nuke here and
there boom boom boom but we're on our
way there
because
Russia wanted these two regions they
wanted dunbas and the other one the
people there are majority Russian they
speak Russian a lot of them are
sympathizers with Russia when zelinski
came into Power which kind of like a CIA
coup uh he eliminated that the
pro-russian party so they had no
representation politically in 2014 Putin
annexed Crimea again another kind of
Russian region and you know now we have
this thing where Putin has invaded the
Ukraine to prevent them from from
whatever you wanted to say whether it's
joining NATO or whatever you know they
he is basically going in there and
saying I want these regions that were
Russian they were Russian I want them
and I don't want Ukraine to join NATO
which he's expanded a bunch of times and
it's it's you know Ukraine's on the
doorstep of Russia he doesn't want
missiles there he doesn't want to that's
what he doesn't want okay now yeah is
Putin a great guy no let's go over all
of the [ __ ] uh qualifiers here about
Putin because I people are going hey
yeah you're like listen he's a bad guy
Putin's not good he kills people
indiscriminately or whatever if they're
a threat to him he kills them he
murdered this journalist anapoliskaya we
think but he did like he does Alexander
livchenko poisoned him with polonium
everyone's dying now anyone who's ever
said anything negative about the war
they're all dead he's not a good guy he
we get it don't mistake what I'm trying
to say here I'm not a fan of Vladimir
Putin in the in overall you know
appraisal of his character what I am
saying is that
um he wants certain things
like yes would he like to reconstitute
the Soviet Union sure probably I'm sure
he would but he's been very specific
about what he wants in this conflict and
then the the Ukraine and the us we've
been very like General
we've been very like vague and like very
big picture he's been like done boss the
other one find me the name of the other
one done boss the other one respectfully
I'm you know done boss the other one and
uh he wants that and no NATO and then
our response is freedom like that's our
response our response is like Freedom
Ukraine zielinski love Nations trans
people dance
the free you know future the children
and he's been like no no done boss and
that other thing and no NATO and then
our response to that is like here's a
Ukrainian folk song and how dare you
it's like you know and then zelinski the
other day goes I'm not
I'm not negotiating with Putin this is
one of my favorite things I've ever seen
he goes we can have no negotiations with
Putin because he's a leader with no
future it's like
who decided that like he has a future in
Russia
the coups did not work he's still there
I remember in the beginning everyone's
like the Russians will turn on him
they'll kill him they haven't he's still
there he has a future in Russia so now
zielinski is calling essentially for the
removal of the the leader of the country
that has the largest nuclear Arsenal in
the world someone in our government has
to shut him up
someone in our government has to go you
can't you can't do this
this is not appropriate to say that
Putin is a leader with no future it what
do you how does this work out in
everyone's head again I'm not a
geopolitical strategist I'm not a genius
I'm a comedian uh am I right about a lot
of things probably doesn't matter here's
the reality how do we see this working
out Russia taking the owl walking away
Putin looking at the elites of his
country and going yeah well I
embarrassed us all like we couldn't even
beat Ukraine what do you think happens
to him then he will get killed and he
knows that he knows if he doesn't and
then what do you think happens who do
you think takes after uh that takes over
after Vladimir Putin
like uh like a liberal free market no
it'll probably be like another
authoritarian but like they have a list
of guys that could take over after Putin
there's like a list of people
um and if you could grab that there's
like a list of
um generals or whoever that would be
taking Vladimir Putin's Place let's say
there was a coup none of these people
watch RuPaul's Drag Race none of these
people are going to be the types of
people here's some examples to hear the
potential replacements for Putin if
Putin's out
uh here are the progressives that come
in uh they include Alexander bortnikov
Sergey chemazov Sergey narishkin Nikolai
petruskrev Igor Sachin and Sergey shogo
so bordnerkov is the current head of the
FSB
which is the Russian intelligence
service
he's uh one of Putin's strongman he's 70
he's a spy he was a spy in the KGB uh as
well and he uh appeared on the list of
those sanctions by the EU after the
poisoning of Alexa and evalier lovely so
that's that's what option uh coming in
okay
option number two will be uh this
gentleman here
um and this guy's name uh here is
let me see it's uh narishkin
he's the head of the foreign
intelligence service the svr
uh and the head of the Russian
historical society and he met Putin at
St Petersburg when the current President
worked in the city hall and like the
other bortnikov he was also accused of
being behind the volanese poisoning
number two
that is number two
it's good these are the candidates that
are lining up to
replace uh Putin so then we have uh if
you go up here
we have
Sergey chemazov
who is the CEO of rust Tech a
state-owned defense company
um he met Putin during his time in East
Germany his position in charge of the
Russia company has allowed him to build
up a large Fortune he has several luxury
Yachts some Villas in Spain
um
another key
silovarc in Putin circle's Igor section
Head of the State Oil Company Russ naft
again they both well one is Ross tech
one is Russ naft and like chamizoff he
holds one of Russia's greatest fortunes
I would feel more comfortable with the
rich guys because at least they might be
concerned with their own money
um
but go up Sergey show you
is um
one of my favorites this is a great uh
example here
in the military sphere perhaps replacing
Putin will be defense minister Sergey
shogu the military officer of Ukrainian
and tuvan Origins is a government figure
who has held a high-level post since a
collapse of the Soviet Union Shogun is
one of Putin's closest friends uh played
a key role in the annexation of Crimea
and the military operations in Syria
so those are the candidates the
progressive candidates that will replace
Putin and reverse the course of history
in Russia